hello look about the big mood we're back
everybody who is here I'm Nikki I'm Gina
I was totally paying attention I'm both
I'm Jess and we are talking about times
that we doubted ourselves every day
every day every minute of every hour you
know what I'm doubting right now what
I'm doubting myself because I think we
were supposed to change outfits for the
next episode I didn't change either okay
cool cell ops on why pretend it's a
different day yes meanwhile Jess and I
we've changed you know what the thing
and I could feed with me I freaking
steamed up for different outfits I
steamed for different outfits to change
it to them and then my lazy ass is like
but I don't want to change this is comfy
why what are we wearing that's so comfy
weird big you can get for a very limited
time in fact I don't even know if it's
still available within this episode of
14 that's true a limited Valentine's Day
design that we came up with we're gonna
be releasing other merch but not the
banana day it's probably gone by now you
still check the link because that is
where I merch will go when we do have
like the hey [ __ ] merch that no one got
mad at me because when we went to open
up our bank account for big mood I roll
out of bed and I just put the hey [ __ ]
hoodie on and they were like bows you
cannot wear that you get us to monetize
at the bank so times we tatted ourselves
and yes we I mean people doubt
themselves a lot but our 30 can you
think of a time where you were like I
don't know if I can pull this off and
then you [ __ ] did dude me this is so
superficial and stupid but when I was in
high school and before I was gonna go
try out for cheerleading I hella doubted
myself because I was a nerd in middle
school and I was like I'm gonna be cool
in high school we're gonna turn this
ship around I love that research
yeah so then freshman year in high
school I go to do the cheerleader
tryouts I [ __ ] blew everyone out of
the water suck that no I can't do the
splits there's so I never trained
gymnastics or anything so I can't do the
splits I can't do any of the tumbling or
any of that [ __ ] but as far as like the
cheer part like I was so much better
than everyone like the dancing
choreography all that [ __ ] I was like
these [ __ ] desperately want to see
pictures of cheerleader Jess yeah well
we have pictures I've shown pictures but
cheerleaders I wasn't yeah I'm like in
the newspaper to like wow I had the
opposite experience of the chair because
I thought I hella believed in myself
like I've been taking dance since I was
four I like you should have been good at
it yeah and I like I'm really good with
choreography but all of the girls so I
went to a different high school than the
people from my junior high I went to so
I was the only girl from that other
junior high and so all those girls were
cheerleaders from the middle school that
usually people go to that high school
for and so the person the coach of the
cheerleading squad was the same coach
from the middle school so she knew all
the girls except for me and this one
other girl and we were the only two that
didn't make the team but they like
reached out personally and they're like
they're like yeah so like we thought you
were really really good and we really
want you to try out for sophomore year
cheerleading because like you'll
definitely make it it's just that like
we wanted to keep these girls together
and I was like [ __ ] that and that's when
I stopped believing in school and myself
and everything oh God I went Pope could
you a common for cheerleading
yeah yeah I auditioned too and I made it
seem pretty [ __ ] easy
remember I remembered it was
nerve-racking we had cheerleaders from a
college like in the next town over like
these like kind of professional college
cheerleaders were our judges for our
high school cheerleading tryouts and I
was so nervous I feel like I was shaking
the whole time but then I was as I was
watching in the girls I was like oh I
always doubt myself to be honest but
usually I buck and pull [ __ ] off and but
I don't know why every time I still
doubt my yeah it happened I mean so that
reminds me of doing stand-up like I
always like before a show I'm like oh
[ __ ] everyone's gonna be so funny and
then I'm gonna go up and I'm like I
don't know if I'm gonna pull it off but
I got in the habit of actually waiting
in the audience to watch the other
stand-ups before I go up because it made
me feel so much better because I was
like what you tried out were you on the
team yeah oh and then like I I why do we
have the same life we talk about girls
girls you guys had a movie made about
you I think it was called separated at
Birth everyone on my team was they're
all white black cheerleaders but I mean
I remember try I only did it for like I
don't even know how long I did it I quit
because it wasn't what I thought it was
I think I only audition because I wanted
like the validation of like I'm a
cheerleader like you get the uniform and
wear it in the hallway or social yeah
this one friends I wanted to be a
cheerleader cuz I thought that that was
cool and then it didn't do anything for
me so I just like quit and then see
these pictures awesome I wanted me to be
a flier which like a tiny yeah
why are you scared right now I swear to
God I'm a coffin all you [ __ ] real
hard if you guys started getting some
[ __ ] I feel like I'm always donning
myself I don't know if it's the same for
you guys but whenever I just don't think
about it I just kind of do it and it
works out I'm like wow I was reading
this statistic a reading not writing I
don't know if I was reading a statistic
that men will apply for jobs that they
feel at least 60%
so those dick dicks maybe for jobs that
they're only 60 60 percent qualified for
while women feel the need to be 100%
qualified before applying for a job so
it's interesting why like we doubt
ourselves and then we would kill it
because I mean it makes sense that like
most of employers are looking at you
know between the guys and the girls like
guys let's qualify it in there and they
go hey them more they'll they'll accept
them faster because of the confidence
yet I have a great [ __ ] example of
this as of this episode coming out I'm
now unemployed self-employed what I've
never talked about what I did I've
always kept it really low-key because I
didn't want anyone to like find me and
kill me stop I don't know what you guys
are thinking I don't know if you love me
or you hate me so okay so I'm gonna tell
you guys kind of know what I do but I'm
gonna tell you guys what I did it like
how this even okay so I was working on a
law firm this was I'm so excited to tell
finally yes the day has come the day has
come so I was working on a law firm and
like January February and this law firm
was [ __ ] going I was like the firm
was going under it was a bar association
but so I'm sitting at my desk one day
and I hear the the CFO go into the CEOs
office and he is like okay good news
Mach we've got enough in the account to
pay to make payroll and I was like and I
was very concerned like it was a really
beautiful place like in Beverly Hills
and I felt great whatever and and like
also just things weren't working out
there so I was like I need to find
another job
so I I'm so excited to finally say this
so I write when it was really bad I
broke out in full body hives and I was
like I got to get the [ __ ] out of here
but I want something like something fire
I see a job for marketing and comedy and
it was that Live Nation and yeah some of
you I don't know if some of you guys
know about Live Nation owns Ticketmaster
like it is it's a huge come it's huge
it is a multi-billion dollar company in
9:02 100 and so I so my job and this job
where I was interviewing they were about
maybe like 0.8 miles away so I go on my
lunch break and I [ __ ] run across the
street I'm like I had to run through
Beverly Hills like up and down the steps
of the Civic Center to get to this
audition or to get to this interview and
this is such a big position I'm talking
like executive level dude yes name on
the door unlimited lunch in your own
yeah dude like all [ __ ] dude it will
love you I didn't even realize how
serious this job was it was my
responsibility to talk to like the top
agents from like WME WME CAA I met like
the head of comedy at UTA like sat down
of these big [ __ ] media I mean it was
insane like I was in charge of like all
of this [ __ ] we did touring for Dave
Chappelle Ali Wong like like some of the
biggest people Oprah owe everyone huge
and I'm interviewing for this job and
like I'm in there I'm talking to the guy
who actually happens to be like his name
is Jeff he's like a comedy legend and
he's Dave Chappelle's best friend
put him on tour like right after
Chappelle's Show ended like this guy is
[ __ ] legend and I'm interviewing here
and I'm like I'm not gonna get this
I'm absolutely not gonna get this job
but that was my reality of it and then
literally the next [ __ ] day they call
me and they're like can you come in for
another interview and I'm like yeah now
I'm in this other giant boardroom with
these two like women that are very
intimidating and they know this she like
the back of their hand they were like so
who are your favorite comedians and I'm
like don't know like they ask me all
these really intense questions but the
crazy [ __ ] was was I knew the answer to
everything like I had all the answers
it's like I just completely doubted
myself but then when I'm in there it's
just as firing off and I'm like okay
great they call me the next thing I got
the [ __ ] job yeah little did I know
that in my doubt of it and seeing this
whole big picture and seeing myself so
small this comedy division had actually
all spoken word and youtubers tour come
through them so there were people like
kotico and Smosh they were supposed to
be touring and they come to this
decision and they don't know how to
market these acts
so I'm marketer that comes from the
YouTube world and podcasting world so
I'm like I can sell these shows like the
back of my hand no problem I was so
niche and they needed me it's so perfect
dude it was so perfect and I didn't
believe in myself at all and I come in
there I end up being a [ __ ] rock
started the job they didn't want me to
leave it was like so flattering they
made me I couldn't put it in a two weeks
notice they made me put in a month's
notice like she kept texting us she was
like guys they want me to stay for
another two weeks and we're all like no
just quit they need me to stand so may
yeah they literally wanted me to stay
till May like we were working on this
giant festival with Netflix which like
would have been announced and [ __ ] by
now like that's [ __ ] happening and
like I was a part of all of that like
that was my job like little stupid me
with no college degree just out here in
LA and I'm like I work with you [ __ ]
have an office but it's okay
do you want to touch a little bit on
whele because it is still a corporate
job it's still fun headache it's like
yeah it was it was really rough I had to
deal with a lot of angry agents like
essentially and just to like break it
down guys like my god like I know I'm
not trying to make this all about me but
just like so you guys understand the
scope of it I would have to wake up at
6:00 or 7:00 a.m. check all of this [ __ ]
for tours
I had agents in New York like close
wiring what's up with these VIP tickets
and I'd have to all-hands-on-deck like
get on the [ __ ] phone with
Ticketmaster figure all this stuff out
like I feel like Ticketmaster is always
trending because the website breaks
during these shows and I'm on the other
end having to fix all of this it's an
absolute nightmare
I was the national tour director which
means if a show confirmed like for
example I did smosh's tour also did a
tiny meet gang that was like Kody Coast
tour so what happens is my buyer comes
to me he's like alright Beau's we're
going on tour with 30 different cities
so I as the National Director have to
set up the ticketing set up the
marketing and there's locals in each
market that have to report to me and I
have to approve their advertising I have
to approve this so I'm literally in
charge of people that I've never met all
across the country like every day and if
something goes wrong it's my fault so it
was very very stressful
if tickets weren't selling like it was
it was all over like oh my god it was it
was honestly a nightmare and so like
doing this podcast with us like I am
able to comfortably leave that yeah and
I also had another fantastic opportunity
in producing that popped up for me and
this is something I never would have
dreamed for myself it's like I've
literally been doubting myself every day
waking up because I'm like I'm not good
enough for anything like I should just
die right now and end it but it's like
when you don't think about it and you're
just coasting things just come to you
yeah but when we doubt ourselves we stop
them from happening we believe we can
because I feel like didn't you say
before when you were auditioning for
Smosh or when they flew you out here you
thought you didn't get that yes yeah
yeah it was so sure that I didn't get it
like I'm literally there and I'm the
only person that's auditioning and I
called my mom and I was like they're not
gonna hire me and she's like why and I
was like it's not happening
but you know I don't know if it's the
same for you guys but sometimes I feel
like I doubt myself to protect myself
for sure for sure like people have you
know you fear of failure fear of
embarrassment like that it's like a
confirmation that you're not good enough
so a lot of people won't even try
because they'll talk themselves out of
it and be like well I'm not qualified
I'm not good enough because if they
actually did put out a gun on a limb and
try and then get rejected it would
validate that fear that they aren't good
enough I also think that at least for me
I put everyone else on a pedestal where
I'm like well everyone else walking in
the store to get interviewed is probably
so qualified and they look like they
probably run five businesses and they
probably are like super pretty and like
they probably like know how to do a
bunch of stuff and they probably went to
50 different schools and they have all
these degrees and like I just won Oscars
like that's a good thing like Niki up
into eight schools and I could tell you
right now it should've just stayed about
four well you're just like you're
auditioning for they're like the
waitress the quirky waitress yeah like
all these girls were so much better than
me yeah I honestly like I'd be in the
room I do so well on self tapes god I
wasn't a key to go on The Bachelor for
the first time like I started watching
it too and there's this one girl who I
love she's from Virginia Beach and I
loved when she was crying because
everyone else was so pretty and she's
like drop-dead gorgeous and she's like
oh I've only seen one clip and it's a
girl who's like I think he's a pilot it
she's like I'm a flight attendant and
you know like so special and then
literally next girl that comes as I'm a
flight attendant like well I guess
everyone's a [ __ ] fly today also I
would just like to chime in here for you
bachelor fans he's not even a licensed
commercial pilot really no he's not he
literally cannot fly Delta American
Airlines no nothing like he's [ __ ]
that guy there
you got in order to like be an official
pilot you have to fly like 20,000 hours
which is why most pilots are like people
that were in the Navy that yeah but he
just he's just jerking off and like
doing dogfighting Jets there was this
girl that was like she in her opening
she goes I have a really dry sense of
humor but that's the only thing that's
dry about me well that was embarrassing
oh my god I can't believe I said that
and then when she does her 101 like two
hours later with him she goes um sorry
about my opening you handled it so well
and he's like I'm sorry I forgot what
you even said that's the only thing dry
about me and then another girl cuts her
off and like she's like that's the only
thing I've ever said my girlfriend was
on The Bachelor and then like and then
she got eliminated like late game and
then we were text each other and that
whenever there's an episode she's like
no trust me this dude's [ __ ] creepy
as [ __ ] like I'm really glad I wasn't
there and then like it just came out
whatever it was like yeah he's actually
kind of [ __ ] weird dude
the ones the current one right now knows
one of the previous ones all the
diversity bachelor because this guy is
so like just he's just straight white
guy and I see him they have like five or
six black girls on and I'm like I you
know Pete does not want you girls like
southern white girls taking these long
dates with like women that look like
Jess the producers like we need we need
you to space out when you get rid of the
black girls like and like they know they
know he don't want us they know it he's
not working girls like there's asian
girls on there too that I'm like he
doesn't want those it's not what that
ever you know we know when we need we
need a little we can a Brown bachelor
we're yeah there's that yeah and if you
want Obama bachelor
oh dude yeah absolutely can we flash
that picture on the screen our date was
real nice and I just I really want to
make out with you sometimes we doubted
ourselves yeah does instill a lot of
that whole like self-doubt because
you're like you are going in there into
a situation thinking like alright maybe
I got this you talked yourself up and
then you get in a room and everybody is
either just as qualified as you or maybe
even better and you're like holy [ __ ]
maybe I don't got this for me it was
it's true what Bose said like when you
don't try it just kind of happens so
when I was 17 years old I decided to
enter a beauty pageant for shits and
giggles and this was like like oh my god
Jeana right it was this summer I was
like a [ __ ] let's do it and so like I
ended up making it past preliminary so I
was like oh [ __ ] now I tell my family
and so then I went to the competition
and like the main competition was in
Vegas so I went and then I remember like
the day before the competition all the
girls like freaking out studying their
questions and working out and I was even
like a plate of bacon because there was
a buffet at the hotel history the Royal
Court I was just like hated me nobody
took me seriously I don't even know how
to do my own makeup and then and then
there are times when it's like what I
actually had to really do something and
so while back I used to own a talent
agency I opened one up and then the
talent agency I would have to like work
from everything from like the business
to the uniform and what are you using
the uniform a bra that's right here we
go pitties up ladies with more than 80
sizes that's more than any other brand
third love has your perfect size it was
good yeah
and they help you find it by using their
fit finder quiz where you can put in
your strap size your band size your cup
size to make your absolute perfect bra
guys we're wearing them every day they
should be as comfortable as possible and
don't forget they need to make those
boobies look good
they do make them boobies look good I
love that it doesn't have a lot of
padding in it or anything but my boobies
still look good
and also the strap doesn't fall down and
the cups don't get this gap I thought
that you were supposed to have a gap in
it yeah well you know guys comfort and
quality at the perfect fit and that's
what you're gonna get with third love
and I I always say this cuz this is my
personal experience with it but when I
first filled out the fit finder quiz I
didn't I didn't really get my own size
correct and the cool thing was was I
submitted to send my bra back and get a
new one and it asked me just three
really quick questions did this fit how
did this was this too loose or too big
too loose too big too loose too big and
I filled it out I send the bra back
within less than 48 hours they had sent
me a brand new bra and it is perfect I
only have one third love bra and it's in
black and I'm so disappointed that I
don't have a beige one too because I
want to wear it every freaking day it's
so comfortable whenever I see Nikki's
boobs and they look all soft I'm like
please one squeeze ma'am one squeeze
only though and they donate that bra
that gently used bra that you returned
to women in need supporting charities in
their local San Francisco Bay Area and
across the United States yes girls send
it back until they get it right but when
they get it right you are in for a treat
so you guys can get your perfect bra
from third love and right now they are
offering our listeners 15% off of your
first order so go to the third love.com
slash big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off of your
first purchase that's right third love
calm / big mood for 15% off also guys
the panties are so soft please send me
more panties and when you get your bra
and panties on you're gonna want some
clothes over those bra and panties go
ahead and get yourself some stitch fix
I like stitch fix because you can go and
take a quiz where you fill out your
style your body shape the types of
clothes you like things that the styles
that you like I even like how they have
pictures of different outfits and stuff
and you decide if you like it or not and
then from that they determine they pair
you with the stylist and then they kind
of determine your style and they send
you a surprise box of goodies and you
get to try on those goodies for three
days and keep what you like send back
what you don't and if you keep
everything you get a discount on your on
your box the styling fee is waived it's
there's a $20 styling fee and that's
waived or it's actually applied towards
everything that you keep in your box you
can pick between automatic shipments or
get new pieces on demand and they
deliver your favorite clothing shoes and
accessories including brands you know
and love as well as exclusive styles
that you won't find anywhere else
they're jeans are so comfortable I cut
my jeans right yeah yeah I might cut my
jeans - they're so comfortable I don't
holbox I'll know what they did they put
some in them Farber's here on set right
now I wore them today
Oh see we all like those Jews so to get
started today at stitch fix calm / mood
you get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
that's stitch fixed calm / mood stitch
fix calm / mood so what happened at this
talent agency right so I auditioned for
this this this national tour and I ended
up not getting it and then later on I
like a few months later my friends like
hey you know they're competitor needs to
hire girls but they won't work unless
it's with an agency do you want to start
you an agency and I was like yeah sure
[ __ ] it why not and then it was a lot of
doubt this is my first time starting a
business I was like 24 yeah and then
like I had to learn everything on the
fly and I opened it up within like two
weeks so I had to learn like business
license I had to have like a ten million
dollar umbrella insurance thing in case
anything like there's just all this [ __ ]
that I had to learn and I was terrified
the whole time it was just money Gina
thanks but it was just me and I lived on
my own I was by myself and then I ended
up opening a talent agency and I landed
like a multi like with a contract like a
multi-billion dollar huge company that
was a direct competitor of the people
that rejected me oh my god it's amazing
how such a good story doing this and
then it was a there was a lot of doubt
because the all the models that I hired
were older than me so it's like it's
you're working with a bunch of models
which means a lot of ego yeah and they
have to take orders or no orders been
like I'm younger than them and I'm the
one who's hiring them paying them out
and taking care of you know everything
and like flying the mountain [ __ ] so it
was like a lot of doubt for me but then
I realize
I have to have to buck up because yeah I
am younger but I can't fire you this
yeah this is right and actually I had to
fire a girl and she was not happy about
it but it's just like and it was oh I
know part it was just like it's because
I'm younger than you huh you know Gina
can you fire me practice firing me like
how do you do it if you want to keep
your job you coming to my office right
now resources so I ended up touring for
three years and it was just incredible
now it was just so much fun and then I
realized man I really don't want to deal
with models anymore so I got rid of that
and then after that was streaming so i
got into streaming and then I remember
like five minutes or like even like
right before I started streaming it's
like a week before a Streamy I was kind
of like [ __ ] I was I was really doubting
myself because until then I've only done
like traditional like we can edit things
out if I say something wrong whatever
right but this is like live like if I
say the wrong word I'm getting cancelled
immediately you know so and then sorry
I'm I'm really great when I was about to
go live I was like man I'm going to
[ __ ] blow this or what if I'm not
entertaining one of them only
entertaining just because I'm edited
entertaining you know like [ __ ] what
nobody actually really likes me nobody
shows up well if nobody cares about my
stream I'm about to hop on Twitch and I
have like zero viewers you know like
it's I was it was so nerve-racking and
then when I jumped on like hundreds of
people came to like oh my god you're
streaming and then I remember and then I
was talking like how far is this really
gonna go like you know it's just for fun
and then the first donation I thought
was like a hundred bucks and the moment
that popped up
I thought she yeah the moment that
popped up I thought it was fake and then
I looked at it confirm it was real and
then it was just instant balling and I
was I was sobbing my eyes out and
everyone's like whoa whoa
my mom [ __ ] welcome to twist yes I get
it and I'll just watch me but so what he
just threw $100 that means this is great
thank you so much and I'm just just like
sobbing my eyes out and I'm like two
years later I'm just I'm just I think I
screamed hungover the other day and it
was fantastic I feel like those early
signs of success are like they mean the
most cuz you're like that's the time
where you're the most doubt of yourself
and you really need that like boost of
like oh like this I am I am okay to do
this I yeah well if I had to do this
yeah or like I there are times when I'm
like I would have I would sit down have
business meetings or oh my god there is
one where I was brought to like this it
was like a National Geographic thing
like event for like video games and
stuff like that and I didn't know until
five minutes before that I was gonna go
on stage and speak oh [ __ ] but I was
just like what the [ __ ] and this was
like purple pink hair Gina ring yeah I
use that purplish pink hair and then I
was like what the [ __ ] I'm gonna go on
stage and then have you guys ever seen
old school
yeah so I spoke and then I got offstage
out and then be like oh my god you did
fantastic I was like what happened I
blacked out [ __ ] just happened like I
was like it was just a full-on thing and
I saw a video of it I was like tells me
like I can actually do this just
completely blacked out or when I go on
like when I have a business meetings and
then like I had a couple of friends come
with me because I used to work with like
some close friends and then like I would
speak and I would pitch and then
afterwards they're like Gina what the
[ __ ] was that I was like I have no idea
I blocked out like it just happened the
powers of the universe channel through
you all the time yeah I think it's like
I'm doubting myself constantly like even
sometimes when we're filming or if I'm
filming on JK news or something like
that it's like it's almost I feel like
the world stops seconds are ticking by
like each second feels like an hour and
I'm like what am i doing yeah is what
I'm saying even happening like it was
like slow motion like what's happening
right now and then afterwards I watch it
I'm like oh I carried on a lucid
conversation with my head like that it's
almost like an out-of-body experience
yeah it's like when I'm in that meeting
I'm
and they're talking but I'm also
standing here like this [ __ ] actually
sounds pretty good I have such a good
example of this go for it I so when I
worked at the law firm that was about to
[ __ ] go on there was uh there was
this lady that had worked there and she
worked there for 25-30 years and she was
the marketing director and they hired me
on because for the past four years she
was supposed to get let's just say her
name was Lucy Lucy was supposed to get
this marketing plan together for the
longest time they had an executive
committee called XCOM and they also had
the Bo G which is the Board of Governors
and every year they were like Lucy where
is this [ __ ] thing well I wanted her
title so I was trying to push her out of
the gun okay she needed to go anyways
and everyone wanted everyone wanted her
gone she was late 70s so due to some
kind of weird California law they
couldn't fire her because you needed to
have a reason to fire her because you
can't just fire because she's old this
lady had HR complaints at one point she
told somebody in the bo g that uh before
I came there that I was selling lingerie
on YouTube that's just what she told
people so I reported that [ __ ] to HR and
there's not some panties from Bo's did
you yeah gently-used buyers now oh by
the way hey we have a tea spring and
we're gonna be putting those on the T
spring so anyways I want to push this
old [ __ ] out because she was so mean to
me she was just awful to me so we're in
a meeting for beginning the year and
they're like Lucy where is the plan and
so finally I step up I'm like hey if you
guys give me two days to work from home
I'll knock this thing out real fast so I
ended up like writing this 12-page
marketing plan for like 2019 for the
whole company and they were like okay
well we need you to present it and so
obviously I'm extra so I do a whole like
PowerPoint presentation with it to smoke
machines and lights oh dude it was it
was crazy it was crazy because they were
all old and I had to make this like
resonate with them I did this one slide
where it showed like the top companies
like Apple Amazon da-da-da-da-da and
then it showed like these like medium
sized companies like Nike like Bob with
a pretty big company but then it showed
those big companies that were defunct
and I used it to draw like a contrast
and like as I started to say how like
their stuff
like phasing out I like made them like
fade away and I made them realize like
if you guys don't change your ways and
your marketing strategies you're gonna
fade away like these companies and
they're all like well you know but prior
to me going in there so I was super
confident my presentation I feel good
about it I'm feeling great everything
like I'm hot young like I know what I'm
doing this is gonna be great
well they have me come into the Bo G
meeting and these are all attorneys and
they're like 40 50 60 year old attorneys
I had never and they were doing a vote
on something and they were like using
all this weird like Latin language was
so [ __ ] cult and they were trying to
pass this vote on something I have never
been in a room before where every single
person around me was speaking English
but I had no idea what was going on it
was the most intimidating thing ever and
so they had me in ten minutes before my
presentation so I heard all their stuff
and these are the six year old lawyers
that were so smart and like I was I got
so scared like I thought it was gonna
cry I was so anxious and like I had to
do my presentation so the big thing pops
on the screen it's like 2019 realignment
and it's like my presentation and it's
like just go and it's so like I
oh my god I thought I was gonna [ __ ]
pass out it was so bad and so but and I
just kind of like winged it and by the
end of it like literally like one old
lady like stood up and clapped and then
like some other people were like still
sitting and they like just [ __ ]
clapped and then they were she was like
I want her I want her on my team can you
come to my law firm and everyone like
shook my hand and [ __ ] afterwards and
they were like awesome and [ __ ] and then
they were like okay we want you to do
that for the executive committee okay we
want you to do that for this committee
because they were trying to use me to
excite everyone because like the way I
speak and everything to they wanted me
to like show all the other committee
it's like okay guys we're not going
under like this is gonna save [ __ ] and
and all so let me just file a complaint
here that felt really good when I
thought it was all gonna like go under
but my [ __ ] CEO who just kind of was
like using me to bring like a youth in
an energy into the company one day
before a presentation he literally says
to me while he's putting gonna see what
he's like are you ready for your dog and
pony show yeah and I was like [ __ ] and
like I kind of knew what he meant by
that but I literally googled it just to
like really get it and it basically
meant
like an exciting performance with little
to no value like it meant like all like
fluff and that really like [ __ ] hurt
me because all these people like
believed in me and I started to feel
more confident but then I'm like oh
there's some people that are not
vocalizing how they really feel about
everything I'm saying and like I was
gonna have hay to go under that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hurt you go under
it's still running but just barely yeah
I went to visit the other day and it was
it was really cool that everyone was so
like stoked to see me and I felt like I
didn't leave a horrible impression but I
was so scared going to that presentation
but sometimes you gotta like understand
like your value and what you bring to
the table and you can't like compare
yourself to everyone else in the room is
pretty like everyone else may be pretty
but like what else are you bringing like
what is special about you that no one
else can duplicate and you got to remind
yourself of that if you're ever really
doubting it totally it that actually
reminds me of um before I did stand-up I
was I worked for this it's terrifying by
the way I'm so like so I love standing I
admire you for that
I think [ __ ] is gonna be one of the
worst things ever to do for when we go
and do some live show washes are fine
but it's like yeah I guess I guess I get
a [ __ ] thrill and an adrenaline rush
from it I could never sing on stage or
like do something crazy because women
are just not funny
true they all want to sleep with me
they're not there for your comedy
they're there for you I did I was
working for this insurance company and I
was the youngest person to that I was
working for them and there's different
departments there was individual sales
where like your cold calling leads and
like you're sitting and setting up
appointments and whatever and you're
selling insurance that way I wanted to
cold-call companies and sell as employee
benefits and in that department group
sales there were only like old people
that were doing it like old men going
around and like that was their day cold
calling companies and like coming in and
doing employee benefits but there was
this one hot ass like 30 something year
old
star girl that would like that came to
our company and they've gave a speech
and she was doing like group sales in
her area in like Southern California I
was in Central California and and she
inspired me and I was like maybe I can
do it and I didn't think I could get
past the cold calling cuz that [ __ ]
sound scary as [ __ ] I was like I don't
know what to say like I'm just a person
you know getting hung up on build
character no yeah I put together a
script and like my whole goal was like
to just make it sound like it wasn't a
script and like to get like very
charismatic and work on charisma and
stuff you mean like those people would
call me and I still think yeah yeah but
then I feel bad about it after all that
rejection did help doing stand-up and
acting in and auditioning later welcome
to my door and I had my camera doorbell
and he was like raising money for a
church youth whatever to do with drugs
mobile blah and he's like I used to be a
meth head but I'm sober and I'm really
happy for you but I'm not gonna look man
I'm not gonna donate [ __ ] yeah very
happy for you to do that dingdong [ __ ]
to build character so anyway I go like
everyone was like you're way too young
to do group sales and I went and did a
whole like company group sales thing and
sold to like 20 people at a bank that
were all like there to get their buying
their health insurance they were buying
their medical you know everything and I
and I sold them all insurance and the
thing that I loved about it that set me
apart where I would like realized like
what made me valuable was that I was
making them laugh a bunch in my
insurance I was like do a bullet point
make a joke about a story or whatever
and everyone would laugh and that was
the fulfilling part for me and I was
like I don't want to do sales stand-up
in and it builds confidence you know
when you overcome those doubts like oh
I'm too young or I'm too I'm too
inexperienced or I'm too this or that
finding that thing that makes you unique
and then pulling it off and then
realizing that like oh [ __ ] I can do it
it builds more confidence into the next
thing that you're gonna do like how are
you so that at one point they were like
oh no she's way too young to do
no she's gotta be at least 38 from you
young girl hold are you and I looked
young young like when I was 19 I looked
like 14 I also imagine baby Nikki as
Nikki right now a pantsuit - like in a
suit no not a pantsuit like an actual
suit suit like it was like ass - you
know what's funny the wind you know what
the strangest little self-doubt thing I
had that was actually really recent what
so when I was younger I was about 13
years old I threw a birthday party and
only like four people came oh so for my
30th birthday party else in new life I
was like oh yeah no one was gonna cuz
because one okay so I keep to myself a
lot like a lot of friends I don't really
like go out as much you know we talked
about that yeah I know well I mean it's
I've always been like that you know like
even my best friend that literally lives
two miles away from me I see her like
once every two months one time with like
two other [ __ ] you were taking your
cat to the vet and then on your stories
you're hanging up to the house hiking it
was so funny I was talking to my friends
like no one shows up they're like are
you [ __ ] stupid and then a lot of
people should have said there's that one
there was one point in the party I was
like your party - Golden Globe
I literally have that picture of Gina
and I on my fridge like I love Gina flex
on me like I'm hungry
I do feel like when you're not thinking
about it is definitely that she's oh you
don't care when you're just like
experimenting like what this group sales
I was just experimenting so I was having
fun with it but don't when I really care
about something is like when I see [ __ ]
it up yeah I'll just be like never mind
never mind I just forget about it but
like if I'm just on autopilot and like
when it's like something out of
necessity and like I feel like I have to
keep going yeah and I just like don't
think about how much
I like hate myself and it just kind of
keeps going and I think also like I need
the confidence of smelling great yeah
and how do you smell great with
deodorant and that by not sweating and
not letting your Bo drip all over your
sides because when people hug you then
they feel it and they're like what is
that moisture it's sticky and it's in my
line of work I go to conventions a lot
oh here we go and I just want to say
that there's a huge part missing in the
convention and it's deodorant and
sometimes I just want to walk around the
convention and just have people just hey
fi buddy and it just native deodorant
them right because native deodorant as
safe as no aluminum parabens are talked
also its vegan and never tested on
animals except for those goddamn water
buffalos and conventions that smell so
goddamn it and it works really well so
making the solution aluminum free
deodorant does not mean you have to
sacrifice on performance native we'll
keep you smelling and feeling fresh oh
this is the whole night all day long is
it smells really good and that's one of
10 a sense that they have including
their classics and rotating seasonals
you're guaranteed to find one that you
love they're classics tents include
coconut vanilla we saw that that was
like oh yeah and that one yeah
lavender rose which is this one here
cucumber mint and eucalyptus and mints
it's no Russa try so it's free shipping
on every order and offers a 30-day free
returns exchanges in the USA now I use
this because I like smell like lavender
but the problem with a thing with
lavender is that lavender puts you to
sleep yeah so I put it on you're not
always so tired already one
like lemon and grapefruit you smell like
a native get on that coffee since he's
not gonna jumpstart my glands so for 20%
off your purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use the promo code big mood
during checkout again for 20% off for
your stinky ass pits go to Navin Navin
native deodorant calm and use promo code
big mood Navid be overran and you know
what you know when you should use the
odorant especially when when you work
out oh I'm a stinky [ __ ] when I work
Thank You [ __ ] but I got such a heavy
schedule that sometimes I can't fit in a
workout what do I do about it
you could try open fit you know what
open fit is the only fit I get is when I
open my legs okay okay open fit can help
you take all of the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit and we're
not talking about sex
that's not very complex it's a brand new
super simple streaming service that
allows you to work out from the comfort
of your living room and we know some
people like Gina will not leave their
house so maybe this is how you can get
in shape Gina mhm
they have amazing trainers in classes
led by some of the most effective and
engaging trainers in the world you can
also join live real-time workouts with
certified personal trainers that's dope
I actually you know actually saw at my
home gym at my apartment complex I saw
people using their they brought their
tablet into the little yoga studio that
we have and they were doing this and I
saw it and I was like oh I know open fit
that's cool like I watched them do the
workout it was a guy in a girl together
and they were doing open fit together
it's really cute I like that they have a
variety of workouts too yeah one day I'm
feeling bar then the next day I'm
feeling yoga or kickboxing or whatever I
like that there's a person that will be
disappointed in me if I don't do it I
need to be kept it I need to be kept on
the path otherwise I'll be like that's
enough and then when they just keep
counting eight nine
: yeah you have to like follow the
program you kind of feel like because if
you're by yourself sometimes you're like
eight okay yeah so this one kind of
keeps you going a little bit so that's
helpful open fit has changed the way I
work out and with our code mood you can
join me on a fitness journey
personalized just for you so right now
our listeners get a 14-day free trial
membership to open fit when you text
mood to 50 50 50
that's five zero five zero five zero try
it for free or your money back baby it's
entirely risk-free so what do you have
to lose besides the weight try that try
it may I suggest you don't like the
hell-like videos of people teaching you
yeah if they had one of Michael B Jordan
telling me to [ __ ] hard workout I
wish they could do deep fake exercise
videos [ __ ] 18 packs you know what
happened anyways well we do not have
Michael B Jordan but anyways you can get
full access to open fit all the workouts
and nutrition guides totally free for 14
days
again just text mood to five zero five
zero five zero disclaimer standard
message and data rates may apply but
tight you get at iPod yeah but but yeah
well we were saying about like when you
have to power through something like
when you like have to is like usually
when you get it done and you're like
yeah what else can I do
do you guys doubt yourself in your
relationships no no my I think I do
actually I do
I think to even like dating because I've
been dating a little bit and I what I'm
doubting is almost like am i choosing
the right guy or like in am i doing the
right thing on these dates am I being
myself I don't know for some reason I
feel like I'm doubting myself a lot more
now that I'm dating again so I feel that
a lot and I don't know what it's coming
from I don't know if it's like a fear of
rejection a fear of like getting caught
in a new guy that's not good for me yeah
there's like some there's just been a
lot more self-doubt coming into my life
and maybe it means I need to take a
break and not date just yet if I'm not
doubtful of myself well just go ahead
and diagnose Jess right here just feels
like she's not worthy of love so in
order to protect herself she says I'm
not where
not where they know I could never be
worthy and then she just kind of has a
self-fulfilling prophecy and if that's
happening to you then I'll let us know
in the comments thanks weird because
like I have the love of my dad but I
guess because I didn't have love of my
mom I still like feel that yourself love
is like it's the number one thing that
you're thinking of too like if it's if
that's the the biggest gaping hole in
your life yeah that's really the only
hole the one thing that is more
important than your father's loving your
mother's love is how would you rate
yourself love like okay so as Regina's
101 recently my friend was like so when
you were like a little bit chubby
because I had lost like 15 pounds like
when you were chubby err
were you like insecure did you feel
whatever and I was like not really I
think I don't think you understand how
much I love myself okay I'm like yeah
it's actually really unhealthy sometimes
but no I mean it's just one of those
things you're like I do love myself
because like even though my body didn't
look exactly the way I wanted it to look
like it's pretty good it's keeping me
alive yeah I got soft skin yeah yeah the
purpose of your body is more than just
looking good internal organs I think you
know self-love is like a spectrum for me
it also depends on what area it is
because like I think it is the thing
that you're least thinking about that
that you're most secure about because
like I in relationships I always felt
like I bring this to the table and I
knew my value there and like so I would
not you know want to settle with
somebody that didn't recognize that but
in my career I've always been like in
like more like self hating because I go
to auditions and then I don't book an
audition so you don't book it and then
after a while if not booking you're like
it's personal now you know it's not just
like you know I'm a number that they
didn't you know didn't want anymore that
I can always convince myself to a point
but like after a while I'm like consumes
me I'm just not good enough like I'm
just not I hate myself like why can't I
be good enough I study and I study they
study and I just don't ever like get
there and then I get very self-hating
so I guess yeah it's those areas and
then also just what day it is it's a I
love your mic holder that you have this
titty - it's a [ __ ] she was talking
about self-doubting and I'm just looking
like it's a $5,000 titty [ __ ] lobs I
[Applause]
believe my titties to be there we
believed in them and they are my titties
can hold up this might wonder what scale
of 1 to 100 what is your self love that
um I don't really ever think about it
put it I feel like we're gonna need to
do a whole other episode on self-love so
maybe we can focus on that in a hole
because I feel like that's gonna be a
rabbit [ __ ] rabbit [ __ ] but I'm I
don't know it's weird because I feel
like I love myself generally with like a
day-to-day I don't think about it too
much but then once I start to think
about letting someone else love me
that's when I go oh wait like that's
when the doubt kicks I'm like oh wait
like can you really love me or am i
lovable but then like when I'm not
thinking about a man or something else
or friends that maybe don't love me as
much as I love them if I'm just going
about my day I feel like I love myself I
feel happy enough it's just like when
someone else comes into the picture it's
like the doubt comes in I'm like oh wait
do they love me interesting yeah and you
know it's interesting - and this relates
to self-doubt as well I feel like I had
like early successes and I loved myself
the most when I was a child child
because like I hadn't really gotten
rejected yet and like where like I felt
like you know I I was really good in
school like I learned to read when I was
3 and so you know I was always like
ahead of my class like in in school and
people would like teachers would praise
me for that and it was always like very
healthy and I started modeling when I
was a kid and I'm doing like acting
acting work then and I booked every
single audition that I went on and so I
was like hi I'm dope and then like
middle school came crashing down on my
head where I was the same level of smart
as everybody else because we were in
gate classes and then I realized I was
way behind socially like people did not
want to be my friend because I was not
into like middle school stuff I was
still into like cartoons and [ __ ] and my
manager died yeah my like talent manager
and so the new one that I got when I
went on auditions I wasn't booking them
anymore
I tried out for a musical and I was one
of two people that didn't make it past
the singing part and so I just started
like really hating myself like middle
school on where I was like I used to be
so good or like myself and like now I
suck and like no one likes me and I'm
that's when I went down that internet
hole of like my only friends weren't
like ordinary stuff yes you know I was
this just came out from me when
yesterday the other day Jess had asked
me for some like old pictures for
something and I thought about how like
in high school I was like I'm such a
piece of [ __ ] I'm so unfortunate looking
how can anyone know and then I was old
pictures I mean I was like wait I was
kind of hot yeah like it literally took
me like at Legg to be now 28 like to
look back I may be but Sutphin be like
why was I so upset with myself because
that your boy was looking pretty good
yeah like I used to hate it because
people would say look like Julia Stiles
back then because if you look at your
society she she has kind of a round face
and also her eyebrows were kind of like
not really that existent and I look back
and I'm like oh my god I did look like
Julia Stiles and I hated that so I feel
like I still didn't like the way I
looked in high school but I don't know
it's weird because it's like you think
especially to with wait you're like when
you're 21 and you're like a good little
hundred and twenty pounds or something
like that and then you get to your 30s
you're like 135 and you're like I used
to think I was fat self-doubt too can
like cast a reality on us that just
isn't [ __ ] real yeah like when I was
younger I was like oh my god I love I'm
always around these white boys they
don't like me because I'm black
no it's cuz I'm black this is terrible
and then we're gonna look back on it
like your boy was light-skinned the hair
was looking on point
the I always have made a full face of
makeup on I looked good and like I think
it's that sometimes white guys were
afraid to approach me because they
thought like racially we were divided or
something in in like in retrospect I'm
like I know those little white boys
wanted to taste the chocolate like I
feel that way about the guys too I'm
like well they I needed to stay away
they talked to me like out of their way
they would absolutely wanted a little
taste like I'm black nobody wants me and
then I was like dude I should have been
out there like you ever seen a black
coat pink nipples before God imagine if
we didn't hold ourselves back so like
put ourselves out there like yeah it's
true like if we fail at something we
like have to find a reason for it we're
like oh it's cuz of fish and then we
cling to that and we decide this is the
reason and then later on you find out
like that's not the reason at all like
it's not like that's so [ __ ] funny we
decide this is the reason we figured it
out and this is what it is you know we
are the stories we tell ourselves so
make sure you tell yourself a good one
out there also make sure you're you know
checking out the merch subscribing
reading our show five stars it really
helps us a lot
and we love you all out there we hope
that you enjoy being part of our little
girl group conversations I don't doubt
your love
my mouth media polish devolves into a
puddle now bounce of Neapolitan Tom
about some get a lick